this is test one
the katesby tunnel in northamptonshire
England used to be for trains it was
built by the victorians in 1897 but fell
into disrepair after the line that went
through it was closed in the 60s it was
abandoned for many years but now it's a
vehicle testing facility you know wind
tunnel this is a more realistic version
of that where the air isn't moving but
the car definitely is so cakesby tunnel
is 2.7 kilometers long it's got a cross
section of 42 meters squared perfectly
straight it's quite an amazing feat
considering the victorians built it
without a laser level obviously the
surface of the Earth is is curved but
cakesby tunnel is flat so if you pull a
laser line along it we're within three
millimeters of being off that laser line
but when we first inquired about
repurposing KP tunnel it was totally
derelict they ripped up the track they'd
taken away the ballast they destroyed
the drainage so at the far end the
tunnels actually knee-deep in water
there were no facilities or utilities
here there were bats living within the
tunnel that we had to tread carefully
around so at the far end of the tunnel
and they've actually got their own bat
hotel when we test outside we've got the
wind we've got the rain we've got other
vehicles we've got lumps and bumps in
the road we want to remove those and
make us control a condition as possible
so the test is only seeing the changes
that we're looking for we're doing a
coast down test here Julian got the car
up to 130 kilometers an hour very
quickly and then he took his foot off
the accelerator and just started coast
in neutral this tunnel is long enough
that there'll be a couple of minutes
before he has to touch the brakes from
that you can work out the drag and
friction forces which is really useful
data for car manufacturers because
cakesby tunnel is a bit different to a
normal wind tunnel we have to collect
data on board we can't use GPS because
we can't see the satellites in the sky
the approach that we've come to is an
image based system there's 1200 tanks
now in the tunnels and they are five
meters apart and they've been surveyed
to within a few millimeters each
position and then we measure the time it
takes to go between each tag and that's
picked up by this high-speed camera
that's working 100 times a second and
that gives us a very high accuracy for
Speed of about a hundredth of a
kilometer an hour the tunnel is a
fantastic place for this kind of
measurement because there is no
extraneous sunlight and sunlight is very
difficult to cope with when you're
working with infrared but I said that
this was test one and it was I wasn't
lying but like any video about cars you
didn't see it from Just One angle there
were camera shots from all around the
tunnel to get different angles and keep
it interesting there were shots from
cameras that were attached to the car
with suction cups for dynamic shots from
almost impossible angles but this is a
proper glossy car video we don't want to
see those suction cup cameras from
outside and beside we've only got two of
them and we don't see the camera
operator in the back either because he's
not there there's got to be a little bit
of unreality to this that no one will
notice once it's all edited together so
when I said this is test one that is
actually true this right now is test one
but the shots from outside we haven't
filmed them yet we're gonna have to go
back and forth in this tunnel 15 20
times before we've got every angle we
need to make this look interesting so I
had a thought do those cameras actually
affect the results if you've got a
camera on the outside of your car how
much more fuel are you actually using
how's that for timing
[Laughter]
typically we go out and back for a test
and average over both of those sections
we have a turntable at each end the
turntable takes about 20 seconds to turn
around we don't have access at the far
end of the tunnel so we have to turn
around inside it saves doing in Austin
Powers 37 point turn at the far end
so exactly the same test the other way
yes okay
go for it
in order to get the best accuracy the
driver has to be very consistent and he
has to do the same thing time after time
you have to drive in a very straight
line so any deviation that adds to the
distance and the drag that the car is
experiencing you can start off at pretty
much any speed as long as it's above the
start of your Coast Down Speed you want
to let the car settle a bit because the
moment you put it into neutral the car
will start to rock backwards and
forwards a little bit and all these
little things all add up so a garage
door opener it is just for the turntable
yeah that's nice
I feel like this needs the music from
Thunderbirds
so the whole idea of Kate speed tunnel
is to create a constant atmospheric
conditions we shut the doors at both
ends and we've sealed the tunnel so
there's no wind coming through it
because we're surrounded by Earth
actually means that the temperature
within the tunnel is within one or two
degrees all year round we had the Aston
Martin Valkyrie in the tunnel we've had
cyclists in here doing drafting which is
fairly unique something that you can't
do in other places one of the biggest
issues is is what happens if there's an
accident in the tunnel and how do we get
to them so throughout every test we have
a fire safety team on site there there
to respond if there is an accident there
is a very slight gradient to this tunnel
and while I'm sure some of the marketing
team would be very happy if it was
perfectly flat turns out there is a
little bit of an advantage to that
gradient because drag increases with the
square of speed but friction increases
linearly so if you have one test going
very slightly downhill on one test going
very slightly uphill in theory you can
separate those two factors out from each
other with a lot of math that I do not
understand the case paternal surface is
an asphalt surface typical of an a road
that you would see outside but just
finished as high tolerance as we can get
I do like how you stick to one side of
the tunnel like it's a two-way Road it
just seems wrong barreling that fast
down the center of a road yeah and also
for consistency for the aerodynamic wake
on where you are yeah in the tunnel yeah
foreign
so I've been kept in the dark for about
20 minutes now while you Wrangle data
what do we have well this is an example
of one of the coast down tests the dark
blue line is the speed yeah so that's us
accelerating rapidly up to 230 then pop
it into neutral and then Coast down to
about 40. and then break so you don't
hit the barrels don't hit the barrels so
we had like four or five runs with a
clean car yeah we had
five six runs with the GoPros in varying
configuration so we've got some sort of
drag from some sort of camera yes
exactly and you can see from 130 to 120
yep gloves an hour it took 7.04 that
time and 7.03 that time
so 100 of a second difference you just
would you wouldn't get that outside yeah
it just wouldn't happen and then with
the GoPros on from 130 to 120 to 6.98
and 6.97 again hundredth of a second
difference yep incredible but there is a
very notable difference between having a
clean car and when you've got the GoPros
on the outside it's measuring just a
small difference of about 0.8 between
the two and does that map to fuel usage
yeah and this is not the most scientific
test we did a couple runs the GoPros
were all over the place but there is
enough drag from them that you can
measure it in there and there would be
some effect on fuel yes now of course we
were using the ideal car for this test
because the weight doesn't change from
test to test
fossil fuel car yeah of course you've
got to make sure that you don't let that
tank go too empty and there's lots of
things you have to take into account
yeah so there's roughly 0.8 percent more
drag on the car from sticking a couple
of GoPros somewhere yes absolutely
it's the closest I've got to science in
a long time thank you very much no
problem thank you